what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so with the war Thor story almost
finished I think we have like one issue
left I figured we go ahead and cover
what's probably one of the most
important Thor stories really within the
last maybe five years of Marvel Comics
if those of the guys who don't know
right now the writer of Thor is a guy
named Jason Aaron and he's literally
been crafting this amazing Thor run that
stretches all the way back to original
sin maybe even before then probably with
Thor god of thunder and it runs all the
way up to the modern day and it's just
this great big huge epic but in the
middle of all this Marvel launched a
story called seeker wars and Secret Wars
initially seemed like it was gonna be a
reboot it turns out it's not Marvel does
kind of continued on from Secret Wars
but in that event they had a series of
stories now they were kind of grouped
into two different things
you had battle world and you had war
zones battle world is what we care about
because what it does is it basically
gives us a tour of the different
universes so to speak that are combined
in battle world those of you guys who
never read Secret Wars the idea was that
Marvel was really again teasing this
idea of a reboot and so what they did is
they crafted this huge story that took
place and Avengers and New Avengers that
ran for about three years and it all
culminated in Doctor Doom basically
getting the power of God and the result
was that when all the universes were
collapsing in on each other he just
reached out and grabbed whatever
universes he could preserve and then
brought them all together in a place
called battle world now of course at the
conclusion of Secret Wars Reed Richards
of the Fantastic Four fixed everything
everything went back to normal but
during this time on battle world is
basically all these these different
universes sitting side by side now in
order to basically maintain law and
order Marvel started crafting these
little things here and there and one of
them was called the Thor core and the
Thor core is basically just the police
force of battle wound but the cool thing
about the Thor core is it's basically
everybody who's ever lifted a hammer for
now for the most part in Marvel Comics
that's less than 20 people who have
actually gone and picked up Thor's
hammer and used it and we're including
main Marvel Universe stories what-if
stories brief moments and time different
things like that where like somebody
picked it up for over the span of like
maybe three minutes and then you know
put it back down or they slightly picked
it up or whatever the case may be but
then there's also just characters who
we've never seen left the hammer of Thor
but it would be cool if they did and the
way this works really the way the Thor's
picks up is it actually picks up with a
murder because one of the first things
we see are really one of the first major
characters we see is Alton
universe Thor now remember in Marvel
Comics the Ultimate Universe was
designed to be more grounded it was
basically designed to answer the
question what if superheroes existed in
the wheel world and so the result was
that we started getting characters like
Donald Blake who may may or may not have
actually been Thor but we also got
ultimate universe the word ultimate
universe Thor was really kind of a cool
character because he was a lot more
brutal in comparison to the main Marvel
Universe Thor who was really more of
like fantasy and adventure so because of
this a lot of fans out there loved
ultimate universe Thor but the other
character that I also want to point out
here is a guy named beta ray bill now
beta ray bill is probably one of the
most important characters in the will of
the Thor mythos and the reason why is
because of Marvel Comics it was just
this established thing that for years
and years and years and years
what made Thor unique was that nobody
could lift his hammer nobody could pick
up the hammer of Odin's son enter beta
ray bill beta ray bill was actually part
of a race called a korbinites and we'll
talk more about this when we get into
the story a storm breaker the saga of
beta ray bill as part of our health or
run but the reason why beta ray bill is
so important is because he was the first
person to ever lift the hammer of Thor
and this literally opened the floodgates
now when he first picked up the hammer
of Thor and actually got the whole fort
outfit and so on and so forth fans were
just like what it was it was one of the
craziest things but eventually beta ray
bill got his own hammer in the form of
storm breaker but what this does and
again what the story really focuses on
is the idea that when it comes to the
concept of the Thor core it's literally
a testing of sorts and it's actually
pretty efficient the way it works this
little tidbit was covered in the main
secret war story it's actually not
covered in Thor's itself but the idea is
that there are basically various
individuals who exist all across battle
world who will basically go to Doom
guard who will go to like the home for
the Thor Corps and they'll try to lift
the hammer if they can pick up the
hammer of Thor they're worthy and
they're inducted into the Thor Court if
they cannot pick up the hammer they're
just sent back home again so it's really
kind of cool the way this whole thing's
works but we get characters like like
Groot who somehow became Thor in a
different universe things along those
lines but the question being asked here
is who is this person and why are they
dead but we also end up figuring out
what we also end up finding out is that
this person's actually been dead for
quite some time the issue is that
someone moved their body and that's the
question is who was it that moved the
body of this individual now a couple of
characters that I also want
point out here are storm four and rune
Thor now storm Thor is an actual story
that actually happened in Marvel Comics
were storm picked up the hammer of Thor
and it was actually pretty cool there's
another instance though where we have
room for and I don't really know
anything about this guy in truth there's
what's called rune keen Thor and then
there's this guy ruined Thor ruin King
Thor was basically this demigod it was
when Odin's son gained all the power of
the odinforce in addition to like the
power of the runes of Asgard whatever
that means but it basically made him
like this universe multiversal level
threat meaning he could do almost
anything he wanted to this is not rune
King Thor this is just rune Thor he
never really existed beforehand but the
other thing about this is that because
ultimate Thor is so lauded by the other
members of the Thor Court I basically
look at him as the guy who can solve
almost any problem now because of this
it really leads to beta ray bill and
ultimate for just going through and
trying to track down who it was at
committing these crimes and so on and so
forth now what we actually end up doing
is transitioning to the main base of
operations and the leader of the Thor
Court who's old King Thor now this
version of Odin's son appeared as part
of Jason Aaron's run when it came to his
own run on you know like Galactus
invading earth and so on and so forth
and the main Marvel Universe this was a
verdant a version of Odin Sun that
existed far into the distant future when
Loki had actually obliterated the
entirety of humanity killed all the
superheroes and destroyed earth he's
basically just the oldest and the wisest
of all the Thor's he's basically lived
for thousands of years seen and done a
whole lot of things now the other thing
to keep in mind here is that none of
these characters really referenced their
pasts and the reason why is because when
when Doctor Doom became God and he
create a battle world he basically wiped
everybody's memory of the way that
things were supposed to be now this
served two purposes the first was to
create stories like this where
characters don't reference their own
past they're just kind of living in the
moment and they believe that what's
around them is the way it's always been
the other half is to actually allow the
secret war story to unfold because
remember the way the the main secret war
story happened is you ended up having
the collapse of the multiverse and then
the creation of data world by Doctor
Doom and all the inhabitants believed
that the world around them is the way
it's always been but this set the stage
for the survivors of the ultimate
universe and they're survivors of the
main Marvel Universe who had stowed away
on ships to basically emerge and then
look around and say this is not how
things are supposed to be and so
it allowed the event to actually
transpire the way it was supposed to now
this allowed a lot of the heroes to go
around and start quote-unquote waking up
other people within within battleworld
and then staged a coup against Doctor
Doom and so on and so forth but within
the confines of this again this is
strictly just for stuff now at this
point because of the fact that you know
ultimate Thor is trying to figure out
what's going on so on and so forth he
actually goes to visit throg now throgs
one of the coolest characters in Marvel
if I remember correctly throg is the
result of a prank by Loki I think it was
where he turned Thor into a frog the
difference is that instead of this being
like you know a past version or
something like that this character
actually hails from a universe where
Thor was never turned back into his
normal self instead he just continued on
as a frog and so that's kind of the cool
thing here is because throg is basically
like the forensics guy of the Thor Court
now as they begin going through one of
the first things that you know throg
really hints to an ultimate floor it
picks up is that all these characters
are named Jane Foster and we do not know
what they have in common
aside from that and that's the whole
detective aspect coming into play when
it comes to the story and so one of the
other things that I want you to notice
here is that as we transition through
they actually pick up in a bar and then
we end up seeing Odin's son like the
main Marvel Universe Thor who's just a
guy ranting outside of a bar that's it
that's how he's introduced ultimately
what we end up finding out is that beta
ray bill basically has spies of his own
all around these different realms of
battle world because remember in battle
world while all their youth all the
universes so to speak or all the
territories are supposed to remain
isolated and no one's ever supposed to
crossover the Thor core can come and go
as they please because they're the
police force for the entire entire
battle world so what we end up finding
out is one of the spies of beta ray bill
is actually Loki in this story for
volume 1 and that's what we want to call
it there's only one Loki there's no
other Loki's here not only that this is
Loki from the main Marvel Universe
because this is a whodunit sort of
mystery what we end up finding out is
beta ray bill was basically killed by
someone we don't know who it is but
because the last person that he was seen
with was Loki all fingers point to him
now this is kind of interesting because
when it comes to the character of Loki
he's ill-equipped to beat someone to
death who's an Asgardian any normal
human sure but when it comes to an
Asgardian like Thor not really and so
because of this where a funeral is held
for beta ray bill after that is just
like an absolute rampage it's literally
if somebody went out and shot a cop
every single cop in that precinct and
other cops around that precinct are
gonna go on a manhunt trying to find the
guy who did it now the cool thing about
this is it also gives us this little
tour of battle world in the sense they
travel to Greenland where all the
incredible hulks reside and they go
poking around trying to figure out who
it was that killed beta ray bill from
there they go to the land of all the
Ultron's they go to the land of all the
zombies every single last one of them
trying to find who it was that ended up
killing beta ray bill but at this point
what we do is in the midst of this
investigation by ultimate Thor we pick
up with main Marvel Thor and he actually
transitioned in as the guy who tells
ultimate Thor stop asking questions stop
your investigation now now the cool
thing about this is that because those
individuals of the Thor Court are only
those who are worthy to pick up a hammer
main Marvel Universe Thor is not there
remember he lost his ability to wield a
hammer during original sin when Nick
Fury whispered that Gore was right of
course Gore being one of the major
villains and in the Thor god of thunder
story who basically argued that all gods
are the same that all gods were evil but
because of the fact that Odin's son lost
his ability to wield his hammer
he's a Thor but really in name only he's
not actually able to wield a hammer
ultimate Thor really kind of hits at
this and says hey look you might call
yourself a Thor but you're not a Thor
nobody ever saw you being a Thor you're
just a crazy guy who goes on these
little rants in these little waves now
the cool thing about this is it leads to
a direct conflict between the two with
ultimate Thor using his own hammer and
then you know of course main Marvel Thor
using yarn buin the enchanted axe
ultimately as they go through and they
continue this investigation you know
when ultimate Thor is called off and the
conflict ends we end up having him track
down and locate Loki now again Loki is
really just a suspect by circumstance
it's not like they actually have any
evidence against him it's just beta ray
bill was beat to death
Loki was last seen with him Loki
been hunting around and really just kind
of poking around at the crime scenes and
so he seems to be the most likely guy to
have committed the crunch but again it's
because they have nothing else to go on
there's no evidence whatsoever that
anybody in particular was associated
with this crime ultimate Thor doesn't
know who Loki is as far as he's
concerned it's just a guy who committed
crimes and somehow has the ability to
manipulate things with magic but again
keep in mind that when it comes to Loki
in terms of his place in the Asgardian
pantheon he's the magic guy physically
there's no way he'd be able to overpower
anyone who was able to lift a hammer of
Thor and so because of that we as the
reader know there's no way Loki
committed this crime and there's no way
he would have been able to beat beta ray
bill to death later a bill would have
squashed him like a bug but what Loki
actually ends up saying is all those
bodies the bodies of Jane Foster the
body of Donald Blake what was previously
fors alternate personality alternate
persona ah those bodies were already
dead Loki just found them and then
placed them in different locations in an
effort to basically show ultimate thorn
that one of them one of the Thor's is
the one committing this crime who it is
they don't know but because of the fact
that Loki is the god of Lies because of
the fact that he's been skulking around
because he's basically been engaging in
all these different actions that lead
people to believe he's guilty as opposed
to innocent no one actually believes him
except for ultimate Thor if for no other
reason then he realizes he's got no
evidence on this guy and so he's got to
chase whatever lead he can possibly find
and so what he ends up doing is
traveling to a place called the
Deadlands now in battle world as part of
seeker wars the Deadlands was just the
place where all the Marvel Zombies hang
out at that was it it was a place they
were confined to but it was also
considered to be a sentence of execution
and the reason for this is with all
these different you know territories so
to speak under the control of God king
Doom all these territories had barons or
people who were in charge of them if one
of those Baron's did something that
displeased God King doom or if anybody
in battle world did something that
displeased God king doom what he would
do is sentence them to the shield they
would be just tossed over and they would
have to last as long as they could
against the zombies inevitably they
would be consumed and they would become
one of them but rolling just kind of
walking around outside the dead lands
and so what we end up finding out is the
person who's been committing these
crimes is runed Thor now again we don't
know why we have no real information as
to why he did
at least not initially instead his
attack takes off to ultimate ultimate
floor by surprise until he's rescued by
main Marvel Universe Thor until he's
rescued by Odin's son now this leads to
a team-up between the two and what we
also end up learning is that rune Thor
of course travels back to find Loki and
intends to kill him as he's the only
person who witnessed rune Thor killing
beta ray bill and so because of this
again there's no indication as to why
this was done we're not really given any
information here all we know is that he
just went through and started killing
them but what this does is it leads to
ultimate Thor and Odin son for the main
Marvel Universe teaming up and
travelling back to face runed Thor now
again this leads to a massive battle but
the funny thing about this this conflict
actually coincides with the actions of
Jane Foster remember while this story's
going on the survivors of the main
Marvel Universe the survivors of the of
the Ultimate Universe except for you
know ultimate Thor and the main Marvel
Universe Thor they're running around and
they're basically trying to figure out
what's going on and how to defeat God
King doomed because of this what they
end up doing is rallying all these
different forces to their sides all the
incredible Hawks all the force it is
like one of the coolest battles ever
because if he never read Secret Wars
there's this amazing moment goddesses
amazing moment the villain apocalypse
takes on every Thor by himself and just
wreak some like he wrecks every single
four on his own just like it was the
coolest conflicts ever in the history of
comics god I love Secret Wars so much
you know as soon as we get down here I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go back and read that
story again god I love Secret Wars is
such a great story anyway because of the
fact that Jane Foster
basically the version of Thor in the
main Marvel Universe after Odin son lost
his ability to wield his hammer because
she was going through and recruiting all
these Thor's to her saw it it's
literally ultimate Thor and Odin son
just arriving in the middle of all this
so of course they faced off against rune
Thor ruin Thor's defeated and they end
up joining Jane Foster in the midst of
this massive battle to try to topple God
king doom but the cool thing about this
and the reason why this story is so
important is because in the middle of
this massive battle ultimate Thor is
facing off against all these different
forces but he actually ends up having
his hammer knocked away from them it
breaks out of the battle world dimension
it travels into the brilliant as I get I
guess what
pass for the future when battleworld and
everything's fixed and it lands on old
Asgard which is to say where war Thor
shows up and picks up the hammer so
that's why this is so important is
because this directly leads into war
Thor it's literally how war Thor shows
up it's how this hammer got there and is
how war Thor
picks up the hammer and ends up becoming
you know really I guess you know war
Thor basically but again one of my
favorite stories this was so cool in
terms of how it all progressed because
it just leads in you know these into new
things but if you guys are new here to
come this explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the Rob
pork if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]